يوما بعد يوم يتاكد لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين انه لم يعد لديها سبيل للعوده
الى المشهد السياسي المصري واخر هذه
المناسبات هو اعلان المنسق العام للحوار
الوطني ضياء رشوان ان هذا الباب مغلق
تماما امام الجماعه المصنفه كارهابيه في
مصر لا يجوز التصالح الا بين من هم
متساوون في مواقفهم
التصالح مع من قتل وسفك الدماء وادان
القضاء بانه منظمه ارهابيه هناك مشاركه في
الحوار الوطني من قبل من يصنفون كمعارضين
للدوله المصريه ولكنهم اعضاء في احزاب
التزمت بالعمل السياسي ولم تمارس العنف او
الارهاب الحركه المدنيه الديمقراطيه فيها
احزاب وجماعات تحالفت مع جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين في انتخابات 2012
كل الاحزاب بتاعته والقوه بتاعه الحركه
المدنيه قالت انه غير مسموح للاخوان
بالمشاركه في الحوار الوطني نتيجه استخدام
العنف والسلاح عده مصادر اكدت حدوث
اتصالات من اعضاء في الجماعه لتوصيل
الرساله للدوله بالرغبه في المشاركه
والانخراط ولكنها محاولات اصطدمت بابواب
مغلقه المحاولات سبقت الحوار الوطني
بسنوات
لتقديم مبادرات للتفاوض مع الدوله المصريه
وللحوار وللوقف عمل العنف والوقف كل
الفعاليات ولبدء صفحه جديده ولكن كانت
هناك حاله رفض كبيره جدا من الدوله
المصريه في ظل وجود فصائل من الاخوان
المسلمين زي حسمه لواء الثوره
تواصل عمليات العنف المنهج هذا الامر كان
قد اكد عليه الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي قبل 11 شهرا بعدما وجه الدعوه
للحوار الوطني والذي يجمع كافه الاطياف
السياسيه في مصر عدا واحدا
قتلت يبقى النهارده الارضيه المشتركه اللي
بتجمعنا ان الحوار والنقاش مش موجوده لان
انا بتكلم في حوار وانت بتتكلم في ايه
الحوار الوطني يسعى لخلقه حاله من الزخم
السياسي تعيد المصريين لحاله حراك مناسبه
تهيئ لاستقبال استحقاق الانتخابي اتن في
العام المقبل تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات